[Musique]
histoire à l'école je suis dans mon
bureau mais il ya la sécurité de ses
victimes à peine et qui me dit il ya
quatre personnes qui sont venues dans
une voiture et qui vous cherche un
gardien et ou jeudi
comment il était et tout ça va il ya un
autre endroit un café où je vais un mec
qui m'appelle et me dit rien à voir il
ya deux gars qui sont venus qu'ils
cherchent oulala c'est beaucoup la
chapelle l'agent de sécurité de ses 8
qui était devant la porte je suis dit
comment comment ça s'est passé et tous
les mecs étaient un petit peu
ils étaient quatre dans une voiture y en
a un qui est sorti qu'est venu qui m'a
dit ce qu'il est à cyril hanouna mais un
peu menaçants jadeyaoui d'arrêt genies
que tu peux m'envoyer les caméras de
surveillance donc je regarde les caméras
de surveillance je reste devant pour
mort en mai genre une heure et demie je
vois les allers et retours voit une audi
qui s'arrêtent un mec qui pose un truc
sur le sur le siège qui sort qui
arrivent ils à une capuche
il a des lunettes un menaçant quand même
là il dit les ou cyril hanouna
bon on dit on passe à autre chose
ouais là l'après-midi pareil me
reviennent c'est bon c'est pas possible
et tous les mecs me cherche et c'est
donc là je dis bon j'arrive à avoir le
numéro avec le numéro de la plaque avec
la voiture et je demande pendant qu'on
est dans l'émission parce que tout ça se
passe et je suis pendant l'émission et
je dis les gars trouver à qui appartient
cette voiture on sage voilà et là il me
dit voilà on a à lauga apparemment c'est
des mecs qui sont venus de livres ou
tourcoing et qu'ils cherchent
alors moi dans ma tête là je pars dans
un délire je dis ouais c'est sûr c'est
des mecs qui veulent me faire péter
je suis pas bien on rentre chacun chez
soi 3 heures du matin c'est une vraie
histoire
j'appelle le diego jeudi réunit mois une
équipe on part tout de suite à tourcoing
d'après qui réveille tout le monde mais
non on part avec youssef médias ne m'a
pas vous vous dites pas j'ai déjà parce
qu'en fait je vais dire écoute moi je
préfère attaquer
sans rigoler comme en position
d'attaquant ah oui le taux que c'est un
peu arrivé lien pour tous ouais ouais
parce qu'en fait ce qui se passe c'est
que c'est ça je m'oublie de vous dire
c'est que pendant l'émission j'en voyais
des gars tourcoing deux autres gars moi
pourquoi pour voir et pour repérer ils
disent ça y est on a repéré la voiture
ils ont trouvé la voiture et c'est tout
dire que c'est une histoire vraie donc j
à diego où on va on va leur demander où
est cette voiture ce qu'ils avaient
l'adresse du mec avec la plaque et où
ai-je dit on y va on par tourcoing c'est
trois heures du matin on arrive à 4h30
450 vraiment et là on va à l'endroit où
il ya la voiture de qui avait plein de
voitures c'est un parking avec voilà des
immeubles etc et on voit la voiture
ouverte et allumé walhalla mais c'est
quoi cette histoire là on se dit bon les
mecs vous repartir ils vont revenir sur
paris pour interpéter war on regarde
dans la voiture il est plein de
sandwiches par tous genres on voit que
les mecs étaient restés dans la voiture
quand toute la journée
il est 5 heures du matin jeudi
c'est peut-être mieux on va quand même
allé au commissariat pourquoi pour les
prévenir et bah oui comment j'arrive 5
heures du matin je sonne aux
connaissances pourquoi vous faites la
nuda que tu fais là pis bon jeu explique
la faire le mec me dis ouais un truc un
peu bizarre votre histoire tout ça bon
vas-y douce et on va quand même aller
jeter un petit coup d'oeil
moi j'avais j'avais ramené des caméras
surveillant j'avais bien des films et
les caméras purement cindy c'est pas la
même voiture
un look à mon avis c'est ce qu'on
appelle une doublette qui achètent les
deux mêmes voitures et même des mac les
mêmes mais maintenant ils me disent ça
s'emballe on la sent pas moi dans ma
tête
aie aie aie bon c'est sûr on veut nous
faire péter on part du commissariat et
je dis à mes gars réunion
il est 6h30 jeudi et mais qu on a une
heure et demie pour repérer la part tous
égards et à 8 heures on intervient on
arrive
honnêtement 8 heures du matin la ja ont
fait taper un gars nous et non 1 on est
tous à étapes faire jouer s'il vous
plaît le gars il répond pas il dit oui
il ya votre voiture vous avez oublié de
d'arrêter le temps d'enlever la lumière
là le gars sort pour la feria bras pour
lui pas là le gars il arrive il me voit
et on lui explique l'histoire et le gars
fait mais moi je voulais je suis fou
tout ça après des travaux du tout cela
n'appelle pas et je lui ai dit si tu es
chez les confrères
j'appelle son frère et on lui dit
j'appelle honda il appelle son frère de
didier à ton frère de venir on attend
son plat pour voir s'il a la même
version
tu dis est là je son frère il arriver
mais c'est quoi cette histoire
photo là les mecs et c'était juste ça
donc je me suis retrouvé à 8 heures du
matin à pourquoi faire des photos et des
gars et on est reparti et je peux vous
dire dans le fourgon après je suis bien
passer pour un con